this is Tommy a Tasmanian devil he's got  a tough exterior but his species need  all the help they can get the only thing  that this guy has in common with his  cartoon namesake is his temperament when  threatened Tasmanian devils launched  into fits of growling lunging and  otherworldly screams the origin of the  devil part of his name they were once  found all across Australia but now only  survived in the island state of Tasmania  while they'll scavenge for just about  anything alive or dead they're best  known as ferocious predators to small  birds mammals and reptiles but they are  no match for deadly disease the last  wild Tasmanian devil populations have  been plagued by a very specific cancer  of the face causing them to starve the  disease has run rampant but thanks to  concerted efforts this species is  getting back to fighting strength this  is the Tasmanian devil  [Music]